have you always wanted to become a
blogger but you can't edit videos or
write text neural networks can help you
artificial intelligence will write a
text on any topic that interests you
read it aloud
and even put together a video suited to
the topic
artificial intelligence or AI is a
science that aims to create computers
artificial intelligence with human
intelligence if the YouTube music
library isn't enough for you a neural
network can even write you an original
soundtrack
thank you
you can also create an avatar that will
read your text artificial intelligence
is able to create a picture based on any
given topic that you can use as a
thumbnail now you can create an account
and publish your first video subscribe
to our channel to find out more about
the online jungle
[Music]